hi everybody this is senior editor Kevin
van ORD standing in for reviewer Cameron
Wolsey to tell you about Borderlands the
pre-sequel it would be easy to brush
Borderlands the pre-sequel aside as a
rehash of what you've played before and
in all honesty it actually doesn't
change the four player cooperative
formula to drastically
however pre-sequel still manages to
breathe some life into the cold vacuum
of space and flying high in the low
gravity of Elpis Pandora's moon brings a
fresh take on combat and exploration
sadly the story and mission design don't
always keep up
Borderlands the pre-sequel tells the
tale of how Jack a low-level Hyperion
Corporation employee became the face of
Terror known as handsome Jack but the
story behind the villain is it as
interesting as the character himself
Jack shined in Borderlands 2
he was antagonizing sarcastic and
possessed inspiring evil in pre-sequel
his personality quirks er treated his
checklist items to be marked off one by
one
suffice it to say that some of the
narrative threads attaching the game to
its evil are weaker than others and the
laughs aren't nearly as frequent that's
at least in part because old friends
like scooter and tiny Tina have been
supplanted by less interesting
replacements though the hilariously
sadistic nurse Nina is a terrific
addition City Sun obeyed my commands
each of the four new playable vault
hunters comes prepared with a powerful
action skill Athena as the gladiator
equips shield that absorbs a finite
amount of incoming damage before being
hurled back and explosions kinetic
energy vilhelm the enforcer calls on two
flying robotic allies named open Saint
Nisha the gunslinger automatically
targets enemies while earning
but it's claptrap the frag trap that has
the most interesting action skill of
them all claptrap scans the area with
his vault hunter dot exe program and
chooses another vault hunter skill that
best suits the situation with a quick
scan claptrap possesses the might of
Salvador the gun Zurcher or tosses out a
minion trap a miniature version of
himself
minion traps bring humor to any
firefight and when all enemies are gone
claptrap in his robotic minions
sometimes tell each other lame
knock-knock jokes
without air to breathe you must now use
oxygen kids or audience to provide a
steady supply of oxygen but AHS kits are
not unlimited and you must be vigilant
as she be left gasping for air oxygen is
in all too scarce however the lunar
surface is dotted with oxygen geysers
the grief fill your air canister the low
gravity and new weapons also provide a
welcome twist on the old Borderlands
combat formula combat doesn't slow down
with the loss of gravity fact it only
gets more exciting leaping high into the
air allows you to slam back down to the
ground in a powerful air stop which is a
fantastic new way to injure music
traveling across the land can be done by
foot but it's more convenient to use one
of priests equals to new vehicles
unfortunately one of them the moon
button is a disaster on 4 wheels a
slight bump in the road can send it
reeling off course and trying to control
it via mouse and keyboard is nigh
impossible
the stingray a one seated hovercraft is
a far more solid choice
armed with cryo Rockets or a flat cannon
the stingray is slow versatile and a joy
to control but of course this wouldn't
be a borderlands game without awesome
glutes and this is where the pre-sequel
doesn't disappoint
from molly wanda jacobs all of your
favorite death-dealing brands have made
the short jump to pandora's moon whether
you prefer getting up close with a
thunderous shotgun or pick off enemies
with a high precision sniper rifle you
can bet that there's gear that will
enhance your battle proficiency some of
the side quests suffer from pacing
issues side quests have you repeatedly
going through the same areas multiple
times to the point that attempting to
finish every quest is just tires one
level later in the game is nearly devoid
of combat but you're summoned there at
least four times these mostly empty
missions make the game feel loaded with
uninteresting content other issues are
technical it's remarkably easy to get
stuck in walls or behind containers and
characters might clip in the walls
making it difficult to activate or
finish a quest another occasional
irritation is when the game doesn't let
you talk to quest givers in order to
create a mission which requires everyone
to quit and reload repetition and a
lackluster story are its biggest
shortcomings but Elpis provides some
gorgeous scenery in the low gravity
environments bring
you dynamic to exploration and combat it
never reaches the furthest edges of
space but Borderlands the pre-sequel
still offers some of the best of what
the series has to offer good loot good
laughs and good times
you